one of my greatest memories is I was
trying to open a wine bottle at um this
restaurant in Atlanta I couldn't get it
open and he goes give it here he takes
wine bottle puts it between his legs he
said he's a he's strong but he's a thin
you know little guy too hope he he would
hate me saying that I bet he pulls out a
Swiss army knife Jabs stabs it into the
Cork and starts doing the old school
twist with a Swiss army knife and of two
to three minutes into it I'm like is I
am is he gonna seize up am I gonna am I
going to kill this man with trying to
open my bottle so I'm about to stop him
and he rips the cork open and opens it
and pours it for me I was like that was
that was one of the coolest moments ever
what you think I wasn't gonna make it
you think I can't open a bottle of wine
yeah
directed 800 movies